[Musique]
jean luc urbain bonjour et bienvenue
bonjour à l'aube tulio à montigny le
bretonneux dans votre commune
montigny-le-bretonneux maintenant le
maire vous connaissiez ce lieu oui je
vois juste à côté du vélodrome
je connais sur lieu voilà pour être venu
plusieurs fois au vélodrome donc le lieu
ne m'est pas inconnu les différents
lieux de montigny le bretonneux
j'imagine que vous les fréquenter
régulièrement en tout cas ça va de soi
puisque vous avez annoncé vouloir être
un maire de terrain consacrer pleinement
à 100% à votre commune donc vous êtes
présents au quotidien sur
montigny-le-bretonneux bas je suis
présent au quotidien sur montigny et je
veux dire je suis présent depuis déjà de
très nombreuses années puisque je suis
unis montrent un depuis presque 40 ans
et donc
engagé j'irai sur
dans la commune depuis une trentaine
d'années donc je connais bien des enfin
je pense bien que doté lieu vous avez
fait le choix à l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines de ne pas occuper le
poste de vice président vous êtes le
seul des douze maires de l'agglomération
avoir fait ce choix
pourquoi pour vous c'était trop
chronophage de s'impliquer aussi au sein
de l'agglomération en tant que vice
président j'adore c'est effectivement un
des points si vous voulez donc
l'agglomération si j'avais pris une vice
présidence mais à sa supposée une
délégation donc consacrer moins de temps
à montigny un peu plus à l'agglo c'est
pas pour autant que je serai absent
puisque je fais bien sûr partie du
bureau des maires mais mon objectif
c'est quand même de consacrer mon temps
sur montigny parce que je rappellerai
juste une chose c'est que il reste à peu
près deux ans et demi de mandat voire
trois ans si jamais ces élections sont
sans sont prolongées mais quand on prend
une responsabilité que qui est celle
d'être mère en cours de mandat bien il
faut vraiment se consacrer à 100% pour
ne pas dire à 200% et c'est mon objectif
en n'ayant pas pris deux
vice-présidences vous êtes devenu maire
le 16 octobre dernier vous avez succédé
donc un michel laugier qui a été élu
sénateur cette fonction cette prise de
poste en tant que maire et s'est imposé
de suite comment se sont passées les
choses ça serait très prétentieux de
vous dire qu'elle s'est imposée de suite
parce que
entre être maire-adjoint ou adjoint au
maire et être mère ces deux dimensions
j'ai pas dire complètement différentes
mais en tout cas avec un périmètre qui
n'a rien à voir comme vous êtes adjoint
au maire
vous avez une ou deux délégations quand
vous êtes maire d'une commune vous
toucher à tous les domaines donc en
amenant en un mois de temps donc il faut
un peu laissé de temps aux deux du temps
au temps mais j'ai la chance d'avoir une
équipe
extrêmement soudée autour de moi donc
voilà ça va se faire dans les semaines
qui viennent
et j'ai pas vraiment pas d'inquiétude de
ce côté là d'autant que vous avez
annoncé vouloir être aussi dans la
continuité
j'ai annoncé vouloir être dans la
continuité pour la simple et bonne
raison c'est que l'équipe de montigny
ensemble a été élu en 2014 sur la base
d'un programme et donc j'irai quel que
soit l'homme au sens large du terme qui
qui pilote ce programme
tout ce qui a été lancé doit continuer
et tout ce qui reste à venir pareil donc
si vous voulez c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai employé ce mot de
continuité oui je m'inscris dans la
continuité de ce qui a été initié par sa
logique on revient un petit peu plus sur
votre parcours c'est le principe de
cette émission vous êtes arrivé à
montigny le bretonneux il ya quarante
ans vous l'avez dit le premier contact
avec cette commune s'est passé comment
ah ben si vous voulez comme je suis
arrivé il y avait de mémoire à peu près
huit ou neuf mille habitants donc
et ça dans la vie nouvelle en tout cas
c'était vraiment vraiment les prémices
il y avait encore beaucoup de chants
beaucoup de grue
donc voilà je
j'ai découvert cette cette ville
nouvelle et j'ai pu suivre toute son
évolution surtout c'est ça qui est
important dans l'est dans les 40
dernières années
et donc c'est un succès tout à fait
extraordinaire mais ce qui m'a permis
aussi de d'en apprécier les différentes
phases l engagement politique a débuté
seulement en 1995 avec nicolas ben voilà
alors en 1995 nicolas abou m'a demandé
si j'étais ok pour rentrer dans l'équipe
municipale donc la fonction qui était la
mienne auparavant dans le dans le privé
m'a amené à me déplacer énormément donc
je n'avais pas une disponibilité
importante mais l'attrait de la
découverte de la de la chose publique je
dirais était tellement important et
surtout avec
l'autorité de nicolas bouquet bombe ne
pas hésiter un je me suis lancé et sans
parti politique
est-ce que vous avez si à l'époque
gte
rpr et que j'ai quitté que j'ai quittée
après je fais un petit passage à l'udf
et puis finalement je suis au centre et
je m'en porte très bien j'ai une liberté
de parole
ça veut pas dire que si on est dans un
mouvement politique on n'a pas cette
liberté de parole c'est pas du tout mon
propos mais bon en ayant cette en étant
indépendant mais au centre et je sais où
sont mes idées je n'ai pas de souci de
ce côté là vous êtes à présent mère est
ce qu'il ya un moment dans votre
parcours politique ou même peut-être par
la suite vous avez envie de tenter
d'autres aventures pour département à la
région
vous savez bon pour être très clair j'ai
67 ans aujourd'hui je pense qu'à un
moment donné il faut
laisser la place
à toute la génération qui arrive alors
ça veut pas dire pour moi ça ne veut pas
dire est atteint d'un jeunisme qui est
un mot qu'on entend beaucoup parler
actuellement je pense que dans une
équipe il faut avoir une mixité entre ce
qu'un peu plus d'expérience et ceux qui
arrivent en politique
donc non pour répondre clairement à
votre question je n'ai pas d'autre
ambition que celle d'aller jusqu'à la
fin du mandat
je m'occuperai de ma vie personnelle un
peu plus après cette période
ça veut dire que vous avez d'ores et
déjà décidé de ne pas vous présenter aux
prochaines élections municipales
ben on sait pas demain de quoi sera fait
mais sur le principe
allez mettons que les prochaines
élections municipales soit en main en
2020 20 ou 21 70 ans 71 ans bon ça
mérite réflexion sur ses ambitions sur
d'autres mandats vous ne les avez jamais
eu au cours de votre parti si bien sûr
que j'ai eu ici j'aurais bien aimé par
exemple conseiller régional à une époque
bon mais là c'est là où je me suis rendu
compte que si on n'était pas dans un
mouvement politique les choses n'étaient
pas n'était pas aussi simple que ça donc
oui j'ai eu
j'ai eu 7
ce souhait là mais encore une fois mon
jamais une activité professionnelle qui
m'a amené à me déplacer énormément
france est en europe donc il faut à un
moment donné il faut faire la part des
choses vous avez travaillé pour un grand
groupe pétrolier tout à fait vous avez
décidé de continuer cette carrière
professionnelle en même temps que
l'engagement politique
oui parce que j'ai eu la chance grâce à
grâce à nicolas bour au début d'avoir
des mandats qui ne me qui ne mobilisait
pas une présence
importante sur la ville donc j'ai pu
jongler je dirais entre mon activité
professionnelle et celle de la mairie
et puis petit à petit donc je l'arrivée
en retraite et là j'ai été à 100% est
consacrée à la ville et vous avez
beaucoup voyagé vous l'avez dit pendant
votre carrière professionnelle mais
aussi plus jeunes de par la profession
votre père qui était qui était militaire
c'est en effet tout à fait mon père à
mon père était mon père était officier
et donc j'ai eu
la chance on pense que c'est une chance
de découvrir beaucoup de pays d'afrique
et donc beaucoup d'expérience et ces
aller retours entre la france et
l'afrique ont aussi permis de me forger
je dirais une dimension humaine pour
bien apprécier les problèmes qui sont
ceux du continent africain est gérée
découvrir c'est que ces contrées
extraordinaire donc ça a été une
17 ans à peu près
extraordinaire découverte de toute la
vie
en afrique ça enrichit aussi votre
réflexion pour l'engagement politique
aussi peut-être sur honnêtement non
parce que j'étais quand même au départ
très jeune et puis je ne pensais
vraiment vraiment pas à la politique à
l'époque
donc ensuite j'ai suivi un cursus
d'études en angleterre donc non à
l'époque j'étais vraiment consacré
j'irai à mes études et puis ensuite à la
gérer sur le domaine familial c'est lisa
j'ai rencontré mon épouse ma future
épouse en angleterre donc voilà d'abord
il faut pas faut pas se tromper de
priorité dans la vie il ya des étapes de
la vie qu'il faut pas brûler pour passer
à autre chose pour la fin de cet
entretien on va revenir sur saint
quentin en yvelines sur montigny le
bretonneux vous parler de l'évolution
des 40 dernières années
montigny le bretonneux la commune vous
la voyez évolué comment dans les 40
prochaines années avec des enjeux
importants notamment ne serait ce que
sur un plan sportif on est juste à côté
du vélodrome de 2,51 de montremy qui
accueillera les épreuves de cyclisme en
oui alors c'est difficile de faire une
prévision à 40 ans mais si déjà on se
projette dans les dix quinze ans à venir
je crois que ce qui a fait la richesse
de montigny c'est d'abord l'urbanisation
mesurée par rapport aux différents
aux différents quartiers et c'est
surtout ce bassin d'emploi
extraordinaires que nous avons sur 51
évident mais sur sur montigny et ses
équipements phares comme le vélodrome
nous sommes à côté donc il est sûr que
montigny qui a évolué encore en temps je
vois pas comment on pourrait dire
autrement mon il reste une ville
extrêmement jeune il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de pratiquants de différentes
discipline sportive donc les événements
importants tels que le ryder cup
ensuite les jeux olympiques avec les
équipements importants que nous avons la
présence tout de tout à côté de l'île de
loisirs qui va accueillir le stade de
bmx son histoire voilà il faut pas
l'oublier donc tout ceci fait qu on est
dans une dynamique de jeunes de sport de
jeunes moins jeunes de sport qui fait
que c'est une ville qui ne peut qu
évolué que continuer à évoluer en
prenant aussi la dimension de ces
seniors parce que nous nous constatons
depuis quelques années déjà que beaucoup
de parents reviennent s'installer auprès
de leurs enfants pour s'occuper des
petits enfants ça aussi ça fait partie
du cycle de la vie et donc priorité à
chaque moment de la vie chaque étape
voilà c'est ce que je vous disais
quelques instants plus tôt il ya des
priorités à chaque instant de la vie
donc il faut aussi qu'on imagine cette
ville en prenant en compte cette
évolution
ce n'est pas pour rien que montigny
s'est battu pour avoir l'ehpad
avec la résidence service lequel ehpad
va ouvrir en début d'année donc voilà ça
prouve que on est en même temps consacré
aux cons ça qu'en même temps nos efforts
sur les jeunes sur les équipements
sportifs la culture que je que je
n'oublie pas et puis aussi prendre en
compte cette évolution de la population
de montigny trois questions rapides pour
terminer votre livre de chevet mon livre
de chevet mon livre de chevet
la couverture s'écrit avec
trois mots montigny la ville qui vous va
bien de la musique que vous écoutez en
boucle en ce moment j'écoute je suis un
grand passionné de musique classique
donc j'écoute beaucoup beaucoup de
musique classique
ça me détend tu es le dernier film que
vous ayez vu alors le dernier film que
j'ai vu ça remonte à un certain temps
je crois que c'était
je m'en souviens même plus si non non
c'était comment ça s'appelle ce film qui
était sur le guerre de 14 18 avec les
soldats qui faisait une paye là au
moment de noël j'ai pu le nom m'échappe
en même temps que j'avais vous vous
parler mais ça fait quand même quelques
temps que je ne suis pas allé au cinéma
oui faut du temps merci beaucoup dans le
cambouis d'être venu pour ce café policy
magazine cette interview
[Musique]
oui